if you wanted to get from here in London
to here in New York in under two hours
you'd need to be moving fast really fast
Hypersonic to be precise and that's
exactly the aim of Aviation startups
destinous and hermius companies like
these are aiming to build passenger
planes that will travel at Mark V more
than twice the speed of Concord
dramatically reducing the amount of time
it would take to fly anywhere now while
these companies have made progress
developing new engines conducting tests
and signing contracts with Partners
right now they're Hypersonic dreams are
not quite there yet
so as always we're going to look at
where these companies are now where they
want to be in the future and what they
need to do to get there but before we
get into that I want to explain to you
how these companies plan on flying
hypersonically their aim is to create a
new engine by combining turbo jets with
Ramjet technology now if that sounds
familiar you might have seen it in Top
Gun Maverick transitioning to scramjet
albeit with a faster scram change
but if you don't know what any of that
means I asked hermes's CEO to explain it
to me like I was a five-year-old
compressed air you burn it and then you
exhaust it through a nozzle to generate
thrust and on the turbojet side uh you
need a mechanical compressor to compress
the air and you need a turbine to power
the compressor so with a Ramjet you can
press it with a shock wave so the
naturally done just based on the speed
that you're going that's why these
companies plan on using a combination of
both engines a turbojet to take off and
get you fast enough for a Ramjet to kick
in and take you Hypersonic and Ramjet
technology isn't new it's actually been
proven to work years ago what we
demonstrated today is something that
we've been working on in the ground for
over 40 years so now destination are
hoping to use that Tech to carry
passengers in 10 15 years you can have
the first passenger plane not big one
not like you know Boeing 777 can the
small one uh like business that's
Mikhail cockroach CEO of destinas who
hopes to have its 25-seat destinous S
aircraft ready for commercial service by
2030 and Hermes aims to have its 20-seat
Halcyon aircraft carrying paying
passengers by around the same time we're
not so naive to think that we could do
that right off the bat so we've laid out
a road map of three aircraft that will
incrementally buy down the technical
risk as well as a business risk as for
the ticket costs well that will be down
to the airline but Hermie has told me
that much like Concord it could be
charged at a premium price
but all of that is in the future and
right now both of these companies are a
long way from carrying passengers both
have been working on that tricky
turbojet Ramjet Problem by taking
existing engines and modifying them
destinous has also managed to fly some
test flights albeit with smaller scale
models with smaller engines after two
and a half years we tested two
prototypes we are building the
supersonic prototype which will be the
first supersonic Online vehicle in
Europe and both companies are using the
knowledge that they're gaining from
pursuing Hypersonic flight to sell
products and services Hermes plans to
use its development aircraft as a test
bed for the US military signing a 60
million dollar deal with the US Air
Force a couple of the flight test
services that that conducts will provide
those as a service to our customers be
they the US government Ally Partners or
industry
but in order for these companies to
progress from engine testing to
commercial Hypersonic flight they're
going to have to find the solutions to a
lot of unanswered questions for starters
there are physics questions like how to
handle the extreme temperatures as the
aircraft hits its top speed there's also
questions around how passengers will
feel while accelerating to Mark V
because while these aircraft won't go
off like a rocket there still will be a
sustained period where you're
accelerating so the the climb and
acceleration period on a Hypersonic
aircraft will last I'd say 12 to 15
minutes depending on the trajectory then
there's operational questions like how
to avoid creating a sonic boom over land
and how that affects your roots and
scheduling Destiny's told me they'd
still be quicker than most flights even
if they had to travel extra mileage to
avoid land well Hypersonic when you fly
on five six Mark it's like two hours and
hours three hours it's still extremely
fast comparing with a direct flight of
12 hours there's even questions around
how regular these flights would need to
be to become economically successful
after all it's great great saying that
you can fly from London to New York in
90 minutes but that's not much use if
the flight doesn't depart for another
six hours and let's not forget we're now
more connected in the air than we've
ever been before and that means that the
number of people willing to pay a
premium to travel at Ultra fast speeds
could be lower than it used to be all of
that means that the economics around
Hypersonic flight is still wildly
uncertain so for Hypersonic flight to
take off these companies are going to
have to develop their engines flight
test and certify their aircraft receive
regulatory approval for their sonic boom
creating flight establish routes prove
that the experience can be safe and
comfortable and then prove there's a
market for Hypersonic flight that's a
long road to be able to carry paying
passengers so while these companies say
that this technology might be right
around the corner if you want to travel
somewhere hypersonically fast you might
have to wait a while first
[Music]